Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two. David P earlier in the
week said I'm no longer going to be apologizing
and explaining things to the five percent of my
audience that needs things to be explained and
disclaimed. Here's a caller who says, David,
I hate to break it to you. It's not five percent
of your audience, 20 percent of your audience. Is
that dumb? I disagree. But here's the caller.
Speaker 6: Do you think
that it's only five percent of your audience
who requires your what you consider to be
overexplain, David? No one's you're not
really over explaining. Not by a long shot.
Speaker 1: You know what's funny? This guy
is in that five percent. This is a caller
who has called after, I say things like I'm not
for aggression and boots on the ground, you know,
I give all the disclaimers. This is a guy who has
called in completely ignoring everything I said.
Whatever his opinion is, he's in the
group, whether it's the five or 20 percent.
Speaker 6: Number two, I think, is
way more than five percent. Maybe
it could be as high as 20 percent. That's a gut
feeling I have based on life experience and all
other things that go into that mix your education
experiences. I said life experience. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Listen, whether it's five or
20 percent, this guy is in that group
because I've had to explain things multiple times
because he calls in all angry, attributing the the
worst possible faith interpretation of what I
said. So OK. Anyway, it's maybe five percent,
maybe 10. We'll look into that. We have a great
bonus show for you today, unfortunately. And this
is really unfortunate. As predicted, what's going
on in Russia? Ukraine is giving China some ideas,
and Taiwan has now raised its alert level. We're
going to talk about that. Also, Justin Trudeau
has ended his use of the Emergencies Act related
to the Canadian trucker convoy, saying it's no
longer necessary. There were people saying this
is the beginning of a permanent emergencies act.
There was no evidence of that, and
Trudeau has already ended it. And lastly,
the the International Space Station program is
ending, and we're going to talk about what comes
next. All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. I would love for you to sign up and
get instant access. Sign up at Join Packman Gqom.
Unidentified: I'll see you then.